turning back to the u.s we have some
good news out of texas where a
three-year-old boy who was lost in the
woods for three days was found alive and
safe christopher ramirez returned to his
mother on saturday following an intense
search near his home outside of houston
he was found by a neighbor who heard
about the search and decided to help
omar villafranca has more
this is the moment christopher ramirez
and his mother reunited after he had
been missing for three days great news
he is alive and well the three-year-old
was last seen wednesday in grimes county
texas when his mother says he chased the
family's dog into the woods
his mother desperately pleaded with the
public to help find her son saying that
she had only taken her eyes off him for
two minutes before he vanished
members of the community along with more
than 200 law enforcement officials the
fbi and search crews scoured the area
for days and nights with no luck there's
not normally a situation where you have
a three-year-old child who has gone
almost 72 hours with no food no water no
shelter but then after three days of
searching around the clock an
unbelievable discovery the child was
found alive he is alive he's thirsty
he's with his mother and he's going to
the hospital
praise the lord
yes sir again police got a call from a
nearby landowner who went looking for
the boy the man found christopher in the
woods about five miles from where he
disappeared and said the toddler was
naked but appeared calm and unhurt we
never lost faith and we never lost hope
in the fact that christopher would be
found
i'm proud to say we accomplished that
for cbs mornings i'm omar villafranca in
fort worth texas